welcoming to the show this is my hot gay
friend Cody with hot pop-culture gay
news is it games it's pretty gay it's
gonna be pretty gay always I was going I
was trying to make a not gay list and
then it just turned out so you so you
have some so Cody's here to tell me
about what's going on well it's it's
mostly music news if it's if it's pop
culture this week where they got the
voting stuff happening every all the
music people are talking about voting
okay you know so we have Jimbo I'm not
gonna answer that question because that
is my right to not answer that question
is right just like it's my right to vote
or not to vote so um target to the mic
okay so imma see Cody is a very gay all
right
that's why I'm here okay so tell me what
we're what will I learn about doing so
demi lovato made her first appearance
this week today
I'm making her statements about voting
or whatever and since when why is that a
big deal that demi lovato is there she
overdosed like two months ago she hasn't
been seen like at all since okay so demi
lovato overdosed and she hasn't been
seen in a while and this is her like
triumphant comeback - it's not a
triumphant comeback yet we're happy that
she's healthy her mom issued a press
release like a couple weeks are about a
month ago and we knew she was okay she
was alive and everything I don't know
what step she's taking to get better or
anything like that if she's gonna be
doing any music or anything anytime soon
but we do know all the Disney stars that
came out around her time we're all
falling apart right now so good do you
think it has to do with Disney that
people are falling apart no I think it's
the fame game I don't think it's Disney
particularly being famous so young
affects them obviously but it's not
Disney per se it's like all of it it
seems to happen like Britney it happened
to Britney it happens you know it
happens to all of them I guess really
but like all it like we've got now we've
got ariana grande is like mini Britney
any day now like she would you go shave
her head
we wouldn't be surprised any day that
she's just wearing you know a faux hawk
and she looks like Pete Wentz so is that
his name is that she's dating or male
has to get from fall boy Pete Davidson
Pete David's so you think she was crazy
so you have some cover federal a [ __ ]
right there okay okay let's get back to
it back to it so wait ariana grande's
falling apart okay
Demi Lovato almost dies
Selena Gomez checks yourself into a
mental hospital for having a nervous
breakdown what's Justin Bieber gets
married to a girl that he barely knows
no he does no that's not true he's known
her for years
he's her for years but it seems to us
from talking to the mind don't point at
me just talking to the mic well it seems
to us that he doesn't know it's too
closer I don't know this is my first
time I hear so it's okay we you know
what this is what this is exactly the
sellers time we have a hot gay friend
segment
well the gays gonna be like do some
push-ups when I get out of here just I
can come on again so it wouldn't be a
bad thing okay so now we're talking
about Demi Lovato yeah we were talking
about Justin Bieber oh we're back to
book Justin Bieber Justin Bieber to us
it seems like he doesn't know her
because she has it really been in the
picture but this but she actually has
been in the picture they've known each
other for many years since she would
since they both were very young I know
that too but it does it's not the way
that they are now we didn't go through a
good according fruit period with him in
the public eye in the public eye got
right and then he's like married to her
in their super religious and it's weird
and now he's saying that there's part
he's missing something in his life so
we're all like and then you look like a
Tweaker homeless cracked-out person like
two weeks ago okay so anyways they're
all falling apart but on to happier
cheerier news the Spice Girls are gonna
come back the Spice Girls are back this
is the game and this is big in the game
is this is this is big when I I think
that all the news is like it's like it's
generated based on my interest right
because right how come on all the news
sources I got ten into Twitter it's all
Spice Girls okay it's like I said I
wasn't sure on CNN Spice Girls could be
on there now why are Spice Girls so
important to you well they were like the
first music I remember like when I was a
little kid okay all right so Spice Girls
are big the Spice Girls are back I did
not know that so thank you for that news
yeah well besides they all look oldest
[ __ ] and they don't know how to dress
themselves totally flattering at all
yeah but they were famous like how long
ago was this so 21 years ago and it's
the same girls it's the same girls so
good for them good for except me the one
studious [ __ ] that we can't get to come
back to the table the Victoria Beckham
is not gonna do the reunion oh wait a
minute
Victoria Beckham was a Spice Girl you're
a [ __ ] mess right now
I
oh my god I did not know that Victoria
Beckham was a spice girl okay Victor so
Posh Spice
she was posh spice did here posh spice
but I know about pasamonte spices like
they starting to call Victoria posh but
the Spice Girls kind of feel like the
dwarves you know you guys sleeping
dumpy-dumpy I don't know which ones
dumpy don't be a spice girl the
alternate dumpy yeah it would be hot
miss poor okay so like Dorf
so this so the Spice Girls are back and
that's a big deal for you it's not a big
deal for me it's a big deal for all the
gays everyone's super excited all UK is
super excited the world is excited okay
now the tour is limited to the United
Kingdom I guess unless it goes well then
they're gonna expand into a world tour
well I think they could are they okay so
are they making new music see they're
super shady because Victoria was gonna
do it and then she backed out and then
Melanie is sporty spice back up and then
now Victoria they announce that they're
doing it for sure
contracts have been signed okay so
they're kinda and imposters like not
doing it okay well that's big okay that
big news for some posh needs it
sorry to interrupt you but gosh needs it
in the gays all hate her so what does it
feel like being the hated Spice Girl
well that every gay hates her okay well
I leave that out to you people who hates
who H posh okay who's the spy screw you
hate the most
okay good alright what's next
well since I can't I can't access my
list how about Ashlee Simpsons doing
Carl's to your commercials now like yeah
okay I don't see what's the problem with
that what why do you have a problem guys
they're reinter ik redoing it like Paris
like the only Carl's jr. commercial I
ever remember is Paris Hilton on a hood
of a car biting onto a Carl's jr. burger
right okay and that was like when Paris
Hilton actual SIM server famous at like
the same time okay so now Ashley Simpson
dirt she's the face of it now she yeah
she was like way hot now like she's
super duper hot she's mom she's like
she's a hot mom she is a hot mom she's a
MILF she is a total she's like a
XL milf okay I got you and I'm about to
check that out yo yeah and she she's
married to Donna Diana Ross's son so
she's got loads of money she's looking
to all the time and anyways but she's
like mom DUP for the commercial so she's
a rich hot mom that's
you read she's sexy and now she's got
money okay all right yeah she's like
she's super Hollywood and now she's like
representing that in the commercial I
think okay she's like Beverly Hills of
something oh you know Carl's jr. we call
she here
okay hot mom's okay that's I think
that's all I got is that all you got for
this I do have one more if you want to
hear it listen hey over here
okay so Kanye West is going crazy as
always okay and we want to know when
it's gonna stop probably never you
saying the gays want to know or the gays
which are the gays really interested
this is only I'm only representing the
games no you're not just representing
the gays but I'm just curious because
you are the hot gay friend and we want
to know okay so go ahead well everyone's
kind of annoyed and insulted by Kanye at
this point and even kemper kind of
co-signing all this [ __ ] but also
you say that's my opinion
that's me are you saying that the gays
the Kim might lose the gays because of
Kanye's I think of all oh I do think
that's possible you know what we're
gonna we're gonna we're gonna stay tuned
with that we're gonna keep looking at
that in future weeks and future episodes
we'll check back in with Kody is there
anything else you want to is that good
that's good you know so that's that's
well I don't know what you guys thought
about that segment but that is that was
uh you know news from my hot gay friend
so to ed Cody thanks for coming on and
we'll have Cody on in future weeks to
see what's going on in the news